The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So now we
resume after our hiatus
in the introductory theme,
because of the snow day.
We resume the
introductory theme, right?
And this is the second of
three introductory lectures.
And today we deal with the
modal characteristics and role.
So we talk about the different
modes of public transportation
and their characteristics
and what role they play.
We're looking at the range
of modes and services,
the descriptions of each mode.
And we'll do some comparisons
in terms of how they perform.
So what are the
roles for each mode?
When we think about the
different modes that
can be used for
transportation, we
can think in
different dimensions.
And one of them is going from
low density to high density.
That is from very
sparse OD matrices
where origins and
destinations are
both scattered in a geographical
area to a situation where,
along a particular corridor,
there are concentrated origin
destination pairs and
many people wanting
to travel along the corridor.
Obviously this
happens more in cities
than it happens in rural areas.
And we also see
that we can think
about it in that same dimension
from having low vehicle
capacity being necessary
to requiring high vehicle
capacity.
And by capacity, I
mean the capacity
of a vehicle to hold
passengers inside, right?
So in that direction, we have
private modes on the top.
And we have public modes,
so-called public at the bottom.
So we all know what the auto is.
It's a private mode that is
often used a single person,
sometimes by a family.
And yeah, so very low density
of the payer being served.
Then you go to
carpool where people
are more in that same vehicle.
And there might be multiple
stops along the way.
And vanpool, slightly
larger vehicle.
This is often private.
So it could be arrangements
between co-workers
requiring capacity
higher than a normal car.
So they get a van.
And maybe one of them drives
it or maybe they hire a driver.
So then in the public
side we have taxi.
And I'm using the
term here generally.
So you can think of
this as one of the newer
forms of taxi of
transportation that were
companies like Uber and Lyft.
So you might hail a
cab just for yourself.
And that's the extreme.
Or you might use
the pool servicing,
the pool services offered
by those companies,
or you might share a taxi.
So you start increasing the
utilization of that vehicle.
Then we have publicos.
Publicos are-- they
can be cars or vans.
They're operated by a private
driver often in an association.
And they usually
drive these vehicles
along more semi-flexible,
semi-fixed corridors.
So people more or less
know the routes they serve.
They have some flexibility.
So they can say,
well, can you take me,
you know, around the corner.
And they'll do that.
So it's the mode that is sort of
right before formalized public
transportation.
Then we have fixed route bus.
That's the route
one and the buses
here in Boston and in many
places, traditional bus
service.
BRT, which is bus
rapid transit, which
is a mode where buses are being
used to deliver transit that
is generally delivered
via rail services,
light rail services
in particular.
We'll look at some examples
later in this lecture.
And then we have light rail
like Boston's Green Line
and heavy rail, which is the
traditional subway or Metro
system, right?
In the middle sometimes
subscription bus.
So the car services
that are sometimes--
it's oft-- like a
normal sized bus.
It could be paid
for by a company
to get its employees
to the site, right?
So it's somewhere in the middle.
Because it's not public.
So not everybody can use it.
But it's not private.
Because somebody
else, so there's
a third party who is
providing the service.
So along that same direction
of increasing vehicle
capacity and passenger flows.
We can also look at what happens
to the operating arrangements.
And we have three operating
arrangements listed here,
three classes.
What happens to drivers?
What happens to right-of-way?
What happens to
routing and scheduling?
So how much does it
cost to have drivers
operating a private car?
If it's just you, you
don't think about the cost,
although you could assume some
cost for your value of time.
But you're not paying
someone to drive you often.
As you move to van,
as I said earlier,
if it's an arrangement where
you or one of your friends
is the one driving the
van that's free as well.
Or if you hire a driver, then
it becomes a low cost salary
or payment for that
driving service.
Then we have mini bus and bus.
So depending on the
size of the system
and how big the vehicles
are and the context of how
that driver gets hired,
it could be low cost.
But as [INAUDIBLE]
and labor unions,
then the cost starts
increasing, right?
So you have higher
salaries, and especially
as you move towards light
rail and heavy rail,
much higher salaries
for drivers.
However, when we get to heavy
rail, especially the more
modern, the most
advanced systems
of heavy rail, a lot of
these are driverless.
They operate automatically.
And they might have
attendants inside of them.
But they don't necessarily
need to have attendants.
So you could think
in the extreme,
this is coming
back down to, well,
it's a robot
driving the vehicle.
And I don't have to
pay for a driver.
In terms of right-of-way, we
start with shared right-of-way,
so cars, vans, minibuses, and
buses typically share the road
with other cars, right?
So they're sharing the space.
And they're stuck in
traffic, if there is traffic.
For bus, light rail,
you have a mix.
Some of these systems
can operate only
in a shared right-of-way or
only in dedicated corridors
or a mix of both.
So light rail systems, for
example, often have shared--
often have dedicated
right-of-ways,
but when they hit
intersections, they
have to wait like
all the other cars
to cross the intersection,
not always, but often.
And then there's
dedicated right-of-ways,
which is more typical for Metro
systems where it's a tunnel
or it's a grade or
it's up and over, yeah,
like an elevated section.
But it's dedicated
to this Metro system.
So you have a question,
[AUDIENCE],, yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, now, light rail.
What would you call light
rail on certain segments
that needs--
that has its own
complete right-of-way
it's grade separated?
Because they have that--
these big systems where
they're partially light rail
and they're
partially segregated,
and even that heavy
rail that even has
occasional crossing [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
That's right, yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Absolutely.
And that's a great question.
So the question is
why, or how do we
label some services that
share characteristics
that I'm describing.
I'm seeing Metro as this way
and light rail as this way.
But there are, in fact,
systems that combines
some of these characteristics.
So I'm talking about the
stereotypical descriptions
of each system.
And one of the points
of this lecture
is, in fact, that it's blurry.
All these lines are blurry.
And you can combine
different characteristics.
So, yeah.
But it's still
useful as a framework
to think about all
the different modes
and their typical or
stereotypical characteristics.
Right, so, routing
and scheduling,
so if you're in your own car,
it's fully flexible, right?
You decide where the car is,
when it leaves, when it ends,
its trip.
As you move towards
minibus and you're
sharing the ride
with other people,
it might have either fixed
routes or fully flexible
or somewhere in between, like
the Publicos that I described
where there is a
semi-fixed route
but with some
flexibility to deviate
from those to accommodate
certain passenger's
destinations.
And then as we move to
the most formal systems,
it's a picked through--
it's a published service
plan with stops
at certain places
and people know
where to go take it.
Any questions on the
terms of services?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
[INAUDIBLE],, yes?
AUDIENCE: On Publicos.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Typically the
flexibility would be,
would be with the alighting.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yes.
AUDIENCE: You would have
to know where to board.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
That's right.
AUDIENCE: But they could
drop you off anyplace.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yes.
Sometimes you can
call the companies.
And they can communicate and
say, arrange for a pickup.
But most typically, yeah,
you have more flexibility
on the alighting side.
All right.
Other categories.
Let's talk about rights-of-way.
We started talking about that.
So degree of segregation.
We can think about
three different levels,
surface with mixed traffic.
This is typical for
buses or light rail that
has no preferential treatment.
Then we go to
longitudinal separation
with at-grade crossing.
Well, the Green Line here in
Boston is mostly like that,
several benches are like that.
So they run on their own track.
When they hit an
intersection, they
have to wait for the red
light with other cars.
Some sections of the
Green Line are actually
surface with mixed traffic.
I'm thinking about the
last end of the E line.
And then full separation, right?
So that could be at-grade
tunnel, elevated.
Technologies.
Let's talk about technologies.
Support, which is referring
to contact between the vehicle
on the surface, what
counters the force of gravity
essentially for these vehicles.
We have rubber tire
on concrete for buses.
That's typically what it is.
Some trains have that.
If you go through the Metro
system in Paris, for example,
you'll see rubber tire on
concrete for their Metro.
That has a benefit over steel
wheel on steel rail in terms
of the grip, and,
therefore, acceleration
and braking distances.
They can be shorter.
Steel wheel and steel rail is
more common for rail systems.
And the maintenance
cost is lower.
And they last longer.
But they have a lower
coefficient of friction.
So braking distances are longer.
And the capacity to climb
very steep grades is reduced.
You have a question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, do you
think Paris [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
I don't know.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL
SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah, I
don't know why they chose that.
AUDIENCE: I have an answer.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The
Michelin, the company,
when they were rebuilding
the Metro after World War
II put a lot of pressure on
their jeeps [? for climbing ?]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
That sounds more likely.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] of
a conspiracy theory but
[INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Not a conspiracy but,
yeah, the local industry being
favored in the construction
of a system.
That makes a lot
of sense, right?
So, I'll buy that.
Right, so other support systems.
Let's get some ideas.
Besides these very
traditional rubber
on concrete or
rubber and asphalt,
steel wheel on steel rail.
What other forms
of support exist?
Some of them are fancy, some
of them are less common.
Let's start over here with
AUDIENCE: Magnetic levitation.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Magnetic levitation, so Maglev,
right?
You can think about some of the
Japanese systems that do that.
For a very high speed rail,
you want to reduce friction.
So use magnetic levitation
to reduce friction.
Over here.
AUDIENCE: No contact [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah,
well, not a real system yet.
It can't take turns.
But yeah, so air.
It's some other
form of levitation,
right, well, based on
air pressure, and yeah.
Any other ideas?
AUDIENCE: Small
airplanes [INAUDIBLE]..
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
We're not-- well, in this
course, that is right.
It's a form of public
transportation.
In this course we are excluding
some forms of public transit.
We're excluding airplanes.
You could argue that
elevators are a form
of public transportation.
They go up and
down along a track.
And you have stops
that you call.
But we're also excluding them.
So, yes.
I'm thinking more traditionally
but somewhat different
forms of support.
AUDIENCE: Cable cars.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Cable
cars, yes, or gondolas, right?
So suspended cabs that are
taken over the air, yeah.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Right, there's
funiculars, which are
[INAUDIBLE] and are,
sort of, they look
like little a rail car.
But they climb
very steep grades.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Ferries.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Ferries.
So if you go to
Translink in Vancouver,
ferries are part of their
transit system, yeah.
So, OK, I think that
covers some ideas.
Let's talk about guidance now.
And when I say guidance,
I mean lateral control.
What steers the vehicle?
So, traditionally steered
by the driver, right?
That's bus.
For rail, obviously the
vehicle is guided by the track.
And then there are
other forms of steering.
Any ideas of what they could be?
AUDIENCE?
AUDIENCE: I mean, this is
also a little bit, maybe,
little bit into the future
but self-driving vehicles.
GABRIEL
SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yes, so
you have a robot with a Servo
that's steering the thing,
yeah.
We have an example in this
lecture of real systems
that already do that, yeah.
AUDIENCE: There's [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
That's right.
We have a picture of that.
And so great.
All right, great, so,
yeah, examples of that.
Now let's talk about
energy and propulsion.
So for bus, the most
traditional thing
is to have a diesel
internal combustion engine.
It used to be the
conventional engine.
Now they've really improved
with fuel injection
and other technologies.
They've made them clean diesel.
So they control the exhaust.
And these engines can shut
down and start very cleanly
without wasting of fuel.
So, they reduce
pollution and noise.
There's compressed natural
gas and abbreviated CNG.
A lot of the fleet here in
Boston, bus fleet, is CNG.
And they're pretty loud.
And they have a CNG
logo in the back.
So you'll notice
when you see them.
Those are-- they require special
maintenance and refueling
facilities, of course.
And, at least in North America,
CNG was popular for a while.
But now agencies
are switching back
to diesel, and in particular,
clean diesel and hybrid
electric with diesel.
So fully electric buses exist.
And they're getting better.
Battery energy storage
is getting better.
So we have fully electric
buses that can service--
that can provide
service for many hours
without recharge in between.
So that's great.
And as I mentioned,
hybrid diesel electric.
That's very common.
I think it's being the
preferred bus mode now, so
preferred energy system or
propulsion system for buses.
So often how this works is
that you have a diesel--a clean
diesel engine, that powers
an electric generator,
which stores electric energy.
And then on each wheel,
you have electric motors.
So, in fact, the propulsion
directly is electric.
And you're only using the
motor to generate electricity.
So you can get a lot
of fuel efficiency
from that, especially
because all of these buses
stops so often.
Right?
They have very-- a
lot of stop and go.
And so sometimes you
can just kill the engine
when the bus is stopped.
All right, what about control?
So we talked about guidance,
which is lateral control.
What about longitudinal control?
So how do you control
when you stop?
How do you accelerate how
quickly you go or brake?
So we have manual or visual.
So buses are typically
driven by a person who
has a brake and a accelerator.
And they control everything
manually and on site.
There is also
manual with signals.
This is more typically for rail.
You have signals that
might set a limit, a speed
limit on the vehicle
and protect trains
from crashing into each other.
And then there's
fully automatic.
So you have a robot controlling
the longitudinal movement
of the vehicle.
Questions on these technologies?
We'll see some examples.
[AUDIENCE]?
AUDIENCE: In terms of
automatic [INAUDIBLE] as well?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
bus exactly where it is.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
That's right, yeah.
OK, so we talked about
automatic train protection.
Here's how it works.
This is the classical
block system for rails.
And here's how we control
the longitudinal movement
in a system like the red line.
So this is the
fixed block system.
What you do is that you divide
the track into sections.
And the goal of the system
is to prevent trains
from colliding into each other.
So let's suppose that there's a
train right here and in maroon.
And it's occupying
a section of track.
The track knows that a train
is occupying that segment.
And to prevent a
collision, it blocks trains
from entering the
previous segment.
OK?
And how does it do that?
It does that by setting the
speed limit on the segment
to [INAUDIBLE] upstream to 0.
So if a train were to
enter that segment,
it would be braked
automatically.
And then the speed
limit gets increased
as you go farther upstream.
So a train can move
along the track.
But if it gets too close
to the piece of track
to being occupied, it will
have to slow down or brake.
Have you been on a train
here or elsewhere where
you're braked all of
a sudden in the middle
of the track between stations?
Yeah, and then normally you
hear the brakes going off.
And then it starts again.
So what happens in those
cases is that the driver
exceeded the speed limit.
And the automatic train
protection system kicked in.
It brakes, it brings
the train to a halt.
And the driver won't be able
to start the train again
until the pressure on the
brake system is released.
Questions?
AUDIENCE: Do you know that the
DC Metro does not have this?
Because I used to never ride
the front or the back car.
Because they were notorious
for hitting each other,
at least like 10 years ago.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Yeah, they have that.
So if-- they have a system
to prevent collisions.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
If it thinks--
if it's not maintained properly,
then things can happen.
Or it could be that
they haven't enabled it
in some sections of the track.
I don't know the details.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
because there
were a lot of people
that died [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: There was like--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Yeah, so--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] years
ago the DC Metro [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
All right,
so, one of the things with
block systems like this
is that they constrain
the capacity of the line.
If we look at the red
line, in particular,
this is the line that
puts a constraint
on the frequency of service.
Approximately three minutes.
You can't run service
more often than that.
And the red line, because
of this, the way the blocks
were assigned.
So what happens?
As you're moving from
Kendall to Charles MGH,
and particularly in the
segments from MGH to Park,
this segment right here
is downhill, right?
You're going from elevated
downhill to subway.
So you're also going downhill
on steel wheel on steel rail.
And the track may be wet.
Because it was outside.
So there's a concern
that the braking distance
might be quite long.
And to be very safe and
conservative, what happens
is that trains are
not allowed to enter
Park Street until
the train ahead
departs Downtown Crossing.
So you need to clear the
platform of Downtown Crossing.
And only then can you start
moving into Park Street.
So that might cause trains to
be held up at Charles actually.
So, yeah.
So if we look at the time that
it takes the train to close in,
that is from the beginning
when the head of the train
hits the circuit just after
Charles MGH to the time it
actually gets to
Park Street and opens
it's doors, the dwell time at
Park Street serving passengers,
allowing passengers to
get off and to board.
And then you have
the running time
between Park Street
and Downtown Crossing.
And finally the time
it requires a train
to close its doors and exit
and for the tail of the train
to clear the circuit so that
it's no longer occupying
the circuit.
That's about three minutes.
You can't run service
more often than not.
So you would have to change
the blocking, the sign
of this segment to the
red line if you wanted
to increase the frequency.
More modern systems are
indications based train control
systems.
And what happens
in those cases is
that the blocks are not fixed.
They move between vehicles.
A computer will look at the
speeds and the distances
between trains and
generate virtual blocks
that are quite short.
And they can control
with finer precision
how the speed limits
that a train has that
are being applied for safety.
Often, these are in systems that
are automatically controlled.
So you have the
moving block system,
which increases the capacity.
And you have a computer
also regulating
the speed, which eliminates
driver variability
and further increases the
capacity of the system.
Any questions on blocking?
AUDIENCE: What are some
examples of systems
that are the most modern?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: I will
give some examples next slide
actually.
So great segue.
So levels of
automated protection.
So we start with basic.
The Green Line has
no [INAUDIBLE]..
Right?
So, and that's why a few
years ago, somebody was--
well, said the
person was texting.
But then they said there
was a medical problem.
I'm not sure.
So--
AUDIENCE: That's quite
a medical problem.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So, yeah.
So a train rear-ended
another one.
It wasn't too bad.
I don't think
anybody was killed.
But, yeah, so there
are advisory signals
along the track that say, you
should go or you should not go.
Or you should go slowly.
But it's up to the driver
to regulate that speed.
AUDIENCE: On the Green Line
as well one of the provisions
is on the wayside,
the signal [INAUDIBLE]
are so old that if you
get your red signal
and it is not changing
and you wait 60 seconds,
you can proceed through.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Right,
and you have to proceed slowly.
But, yeah.
Right.
So they allow trains to
sometimes to both two trains
to birth on a platform
in some cases,
although they're not
really liking that anymore.
But they used it
a little bit more.
Right, so--
AUDIENCE: And in
Chicago, though,
that train's
[INAUDIBLE] you can call
to get clearance to pull past
the red signal [INAUDIBLE]..
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
That's true for most systems.
You can override.
And with a very slow speed you
can take control and manually--
and you need that, because
sometimes these systems fail.
And they all go red.
So you still have
to move the trains.
And you need this
override system.
But it won't allow
quick movement.
AUDIENCE: That's how we had
runaway train on Red Line.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yep.
OK.
The next level of automation
is manually setting the speed
below the maximum level.
That's the Red Line,
what he just described.
In-cab signals, the speed limit
of the block that the train is
occupying is sent to the
cab so that the driver
knows what the speed limit is.
It's up to the driver to
determine what the speed is.
But if the driver
exceeds that speed,
the automatic train
protection system
kicks in and brakes the
train to a halt. All right?
Then we have manual setting
of dwell times only.
So the train drives
itself between stations.
The driver decides on
the door opening and door
closing manually and,
therefore, controls how long
the doors are open for.
So it's a more advanced
system from the '70s and '80s.
And then we have
semi-automated so we
have automatic train supervision
or automatic train regulation.
A good example of
this is Tren Urbano
in San Juan, Puerto Rico
and the London Underground
central line.
So here the train can
drive itself automatically
between stations.
The driver only pushes
a button to tell
the train go to the next
station essentially.
In Tren Urbano's
case, and I imagine
this is true in all system.
The drivers are
required to manually
operate for small fraction
of their [INAUDIBLE]
to manually control
trains if there
is a failure of the system Eli?
AUDIENCE: But they don't
control dwell times in these?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
They can but often not.
Often the dwell times
are also regulated.
AUDIENCE: They
definitely control them
on the Central Line.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Yeah, so--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] Warning
for the people on the platform.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --people
on the platform.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So you have this button
that you push, the driver,
to sort of authorize
the movement forward.
So you can, right,
you can not press it
and thereby extend
the dwell time.
But the speed between the
stations and everything else
is the parking of the
train at the platform
and the opening of the doors.
It all happens automatically.
Then you have full automation.
And this comes often
with a communications
based train control.
So you could drive this
without any driver inside.
Shut-- airport trains
are often like this.
But we're seeing this in
Metro systems as well.
In some systems, they
still have attendants
or they still have a
driver just in case
or for political reasons.
But these systems
can drive themselves.
You often need
platform screen doors.
That's one of the concerns
with fully automatic systems.
It allows people to
go into the track
and the computer
won't see them, right?
So it has to be a more
controlled system.
Line 14 in Paris is
another example of that.
Yeah, and then you can
[INAUDIBLE] capacity
through a moving block system.
And here's an example of
the C Line in New York City.
Questions?
AUDIENCE: You said
[INAUDIBLE] people [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Yeah, so these systems
have platform screen
doors and they
don't have a driver, right?
So you go in and they
move between stations.
But you also have
lots of Metro systems
in cities that work like that.
As of 2013, there were 48
fully automated Metro lines
in 32 cities over the world
that didn't require a driver
to operate.
And that number is going up.
OK.
Let's talk about bus.
What is a bus?
And [INAUDIBLE] we're talking
about the stereotypical--
this is the what is a bus,
what is a train lecture.
So this is the stereotypical
description of what a bus is.
But of course, the boundaries
between these modes are blurry.
So stereotypical
definitions are of vehicle
operating individually
with rubber tires
with manual lateral and
manual longitudinal control,
so a driver has full control.
Sizes.
They can be small like a minibus
can carry 10 to 20 passengers.
And you could go up to
bi-articulated carrying
as much as a light rail system,
a light rail train, so up
to 250 passengers.
If you at systems like
Curitiba in Brazil.
Vehicle design, you can have
high floor design or low floor
design.
Can somebody suggest
what the difference is
and what the benefit
of low floor is?
Eli?
AUDIENCE: Low floor is better
for wheelchair accessibility.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Uh-huh, there's
another benefit.
So one of the
benefits of low floor
is wheelchair accessibility.
Another benefit?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: The boarcding
time is lower.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Shorter dwell times, right?
These people are not climbing
stairs to get on the vehicle
or off the vehicle.
You can speed up the process
and increase capacity.
Another idea?
AUDIENCE: The ride
is more stable?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: The ride
is more stable.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
I'm not sure that's the case.
I don't think that has
a large impact on--
yeah, on-- I don't think vehicle
design in terms of high floor
or low floor increases
stability that much, not
anyway for the speeds
at which these buses go.
It's not much of a
critical consideration.
OK, right-of-way.
So all options are available.
You could be on the street
sharing your lane with cars.
Or you could have a
dedicated bus lane
with no signals and
preferential treatment
if you have some signals.
So everything goes.
In terms of guidance,
often it is manual.
But sometimes you
have the systems
to automatically guide the bus.
And we'll see two examples of
that later in this lecture.
Propulsion.
All options are available.
You have electric.
You have diesel.
You have hybrid, everything.
And in terms of fare
payment, another key decision
if you're thinking of a
new bus system in your city
is, do you have
the people paying
the fare as they
get on the vehicle
or do you want that to--
do you want that payment
to happen outside?
So are you going to make
some stations where people
pay their fare and then
board without having
to interact with a fare box?
The benefit of the latter
is that you speed up
the dwell times.
But of course, you
need to spend more
on fare gates or some other
means of paying a fare.
AUDIENCE: Is there a benefit
to high floor for urban buses?
GABRIEL
SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: There--
AUDIENCE: Not intercity coaches.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So they are cheaper.
Because it's easier.
You have more space to, right,
to put all the mechanical parts
of the bus.
And I'll actually show
you in some BRT systems,
like, Curitibas, it
is very high floor.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: And
that's a very high capacity.
So, yeah.
So this is a bus.
This is a traditional 40 foot
bus that seats 39 people.
It has capacity for 56
people if you count standees.
You can crush a
few more people in.
Here's a double deck,
capacity for 70 to 80 people.
The upper deck is
for sitting only.
If they see you
standing, the driver
will announce that you have
to sit down for safety though.
Articulated bus in Bogota.
So now you're getting
a bigger size.
You have two sections much like
the light rail, the Green Line
vehicle here in Boston.
But this is a bus.
And bi-articulated so you
can keep adding sections.
This is the example
that I mentioned
where it's a high floor bus.
Notice how high the doors are.
And obviously no one's going
to jump from the street
up or down.
These are [INAUDIBLE]
at specific stations.
Here's the photo.
These are the stations.
You can see other
gates so people
have to enter the stations and
pay their fare as they go in.
And, sorry, and then there
are these little platforms
that stick out.
The bus stops right
in front of those.
And the doors open
wide much like a Metro
door will open very quickly
to allow level boarding.
So this [INAUDIBLE] of
BRT, bus rapid transit,
with all the features
of bus rapid transit.
So you have [INAUDIBLE]
link, fare collection.
You have very wide doors.
So it behaves like
a rail system.
But it's buses that
are serving it.
Were there some questions?
I saw some hands.
Perhaps I answered them.
OK.
Now a minibus, a
very small minibus.
So, if there were a cute bus,
perhaps this is it, right?
So this is in Avignon, France.
It says free service one
bus every six minutes
from 7:30 to 7:30 from
Monday to Saturday.
So this probably
sits 10 people about.
So here's [INAUDIBLE]
Cambridgeshire busway
in the UK.
This is automatically guided.
So the bus has
the mechanical arm
that sticks in
front of the wheels
or behind the
wheels with a curb.
And it sort of holds
laterally against the,
these edges of concrete.
And so if that guideway
turn, the steering wheel
will also turn.
That make sense?
The benefit of this is
that you can run quick.
You can sort of operate at high
speed through narrow sections.
This is more useful in tunnels.
So, for example, the
Silver Line here in Boston
could operate much faster if
it had that system to guide it.
OK.
Here's another
system for guidance.
Can somebody tell
me how this works?
It goes back to what
Emily said earlier.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: What?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Do you notice these lines
on the floor?
So there's a camera looking
down right in front.
And it's-- this camera is
program to automatically steer
the bus such that it
remains along that line.
So the lateral control of
the bus in [INAUDIBLE] it
runs in France.
It is fully automatic.
Eli?
AUDIENCE: What's the
advantage of that?
Like [INAUDIBLE]
dedicated [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
You can [INAUDIBLE]
this is a pretty narrow section
if we're going both ways.
So [INAUDIBLE] computers are
better at controlling things,
so--
and we could highlight
other features
like this sign here saying
when the buses are coming.
And so this is a
nicer bus system
with elements of the BRT.
That's another comment
I want [INAUDIBLE] BRT.
BRT is-- the full BRT is
much like [INAUDIBLE] example
I showed you, but
especially in North America
and actually all over
the world, agencies
are taking elements of BRT and
applying somewhat selectively.
Sometimes they call it
BRT even so they take
the branding of BRT into it.
Hopefully, it's more
than just the branding
and they've taken
other [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
what happens
when the lines get
dirty or there's snow?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Yeah, yeah, I don't know.
I imagine you have to clean
and repaint the lines often.
Or you have to take control.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --radar.
AUDIENCE: Other
places where they
put actually like coils in the
ground and then touch that.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
Yeah.
OK.
Let's talk about light rail.
So stereotypical
description of light rail.
Vehicles operating
individually or in short trains
with electric motors and
overhead power collectors,
steel wheel on steel rail with
manual or automatic signal
control.
So if you were a
consultant and you
were thinking about
[INAUDIBLE] about what, how
you were deciding on the
key aspects of a new system,
you could think
about vehicle design.
Are you going to make it
high floor or low floor?
So some vehicles here
in the Green Line
are-- we have both
on the Green Line.
I don't know if you've noticed.
The older ones are high floor.
You have to go upstairs
to enter the vehicle.
And the more-- the newer
ones are low floor.
You could have articulated
or rigid body vehicles.
Right-of-way, we have
an option just for bus.
And you also have a fully
automated to manually
[INAUDIBLE] or
things in between.
And here are some examples.
We have-- this is in Utah,
so the TRAX, T-R- A-X.
And this one goes
through, I believe
this is an intersection
where cars can cross.
So it's sharing some
aspects of its right of way.
Here's the Metro Blue
Line in Minneapolis.
Both of these take
power electrically
from overhead catenaries
as you see here.
But the third, well,
no, not the third.
Here we also have catenaries.
That's Here is the fourth
example I have of light rail
it has no catenaries.
So this is a more modern
system for powering light rail
that actually
stereotypical description.
So does somebody
know how this works?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] it
has-- you can see three lines.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
There are three lines.
So these two are for guidance.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: And
there's one in the middle.
AUDIENCE: Then one is for power.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
That's the third rail.
So how do you prevent people
from electrocuting themselves
when they walk.
Because typically in Metro
systems a third rail,
it's [INAUDIBLE] Yeah.
Huh?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
induction maybe?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
No, it's contact.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Nope.
It has to be--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: It's in short
insulated sections
that are only active when
the vehicle is going.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
And they're
electronically controlled.
So the head and the
tail of the train
emits some signals
that say, I'm over you.
Open, like, turn the
turn the section on.
And only the section that is
under the vehicle is powered.
The rest of it is disconnected.
So it's prettier.
Because you don't have
these overhead catenaries
that are somewhat
unsightly taking space.
Over in the back?
Sorry.
This is in Bordeaux in France.
AUDIENCE: So is it also
cheaper because it's
in the ground [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
I don't--
I can imagine that it's
more expensive actually.
But I can't say for sure.
It's getting-- you know, when
this started it was a new thing
and there were issues with
[INAUDIBLE] and other things.
It's getting more widespread.
And I think they've solved
a lot of [INAUDIBLE]
It's becoming more common,
so I imagine that the cost
will go down with that.
AUDIENCE: Back in the '50s
and before New York and DC
wouldn't allow overhead
so they actually
had clouds that if they
had conduits in the ground,
they had to have [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Yeah, underground, yeah.
All right.
Stereotypical description
of heavy rail.
Vehicles operating in
trains with electric motors
on fully separated right
of way with manual signal
or automatic longitudinal
control, level boarding
and off-vehicle fare payment.
So Metro, right?
If you were designing
a Metro system,
what would be your
key decisions?
You would think
about train length.
How long will my train be?
It can't be longer
than your platform.
So your station assigned
has to go with this.
If you have old
stations and you're
having a capacity problem, you
can't just buy longer trains.
Some system allow for
the last car to remain,
at least the last
door of the last car
to remain in the tunnel.
In London you see that.
So a [INAUDIBLE] station
saying, if you're
in the rear of the
car, move to the front,
because we're entering
a shorter segment.
So that's one of them.
The other things that
could limit the length
are turning radius radii,
but that's not usually
a problem with Metro.
Because Metro doesn't usually
have very tight curves.
OK.
Right of way.
So you could have it at-grade.
If you have it at-grade that
means that if you want cars
to cross under or over, you have
to do a tunnel or an overpass.
Elevated, [INAUDIBLE] you
were making the overpass kind
of over a long stretch for
the train and allowing--
keeping your streets as they
are and a tunnel [INAUDIBLE]
well [INAUDIBLE].
The Tren Urbano in Puerto
Rico has all three types
of right of ways.
Station spacing is
another consideration.
If you space stations out--
if you have longer distance
between stations that means
you can cover a longer
distance faster.
But that means that
people have to walk longer
to their final origin
or their, sorry,
their first-- the real origin
or their real destination.
And their at both
ends of the trip.
And then operating arrangements.
We talked about the different
blocking systems and control
systems.
Do you want this to
be driven by a human
or will a computer
be taking over?
So questions about this?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So the difference
between heavy and light rail
is it as simple as just
heavy and light rail or--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
No, it has
nothing to do with
whether-- with the weight
of the vehicle for sure.
So, but again, and stereotypes--
AUDIENCE: Well, not of the
vehicle but [INAUDIBLE]
the type of vehicle.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Yeah, [INAUDIBLE] no.
But stereotypically
yes because you
have streetcars, which are the
track is kind of embedded--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
--on the-- and narrower kind
of on the ground.
And then these
heavy rail systems
tend to have a third rail
and sort of wider gauge.
It's for higher capacity.
So here's an example.
This is-- is this
Beijing or Shanghai?
AUDIENCE: Beijing [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
Yeah, Beijing.
Line 4 in Beijing.
And you can see here, so
platform screen doors.
So these will only open
when a train is there.
And it protects
people from being
pushed into the track, which
could happen by accident
or a person trying to commit
suicide, which is actually
a big problem for
Metro operators.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
you mentioned,
do they control the door of
the last car [INAUDIBLE] so--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --they open--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
They don't open the door
that is not-- yeah, yeah.
Only open doors that are right
in front of a platform screen
door if that makes sense.
And it's hard to align
the train very well.
So you often have these, with a
computer controlling the train,
to stop precisely
where the doors are.
AUDIENCE: Do you
know a system of how
they choose the doors,
which one will be open them?
GABRIEL
SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah, I
mean it's just
based on-- the train
will stop so that its first door
aligns with the first platform
screen door.
And everything
else just follows.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Huh?
AUDIENCE: I think he means with
the control system back here.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
[INAUDIBLE]
what communication
happens exactly?
I don't know the
details of each system.
It might be a little
[INAUDIBLE] yeah.
This is [INAUDIBLE].
This is an elevated section.
You see the third rail right
here carrying the power.
Power.
Let's have a quick aside
and talk about power.
There are two electric sort of
categories of [INAUDIBLE] rail
is most likely [INAUDIBLE]
volt direct current power.
And systems that are
longer [INAUDIBLE]
alternating current at 25
kilovolts, so much higher
voltage.
Any ideas about the
trade-offs between these two
or when would you use
one over the other?
AUDIENCE: Third
rail at low speeds?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Maybe.
But more than lower speeds,
it's shorter distances.
So why?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So, if you're-- yeah,
so if you're in a tunnel, the
tunnel construction will be
more expensive if you have to
fit in a catenary and space
for the pick-up, right?
What else?
[INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: I think
a lot of it has
to do with where you
have to build substations
and how power is transmitted.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
And that
is-- that is the key difference.
Yeah, so--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] power
is a lot easier to transfer
[INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Right.
AUDIENCE: --distances but the
cost--it probably cost more
to--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
To maintain the system.
Right.
OK, so AC power, well,
you can change the voltage
on the current, right?
So you can make it
very high voltage.
And that means that it's easy
and cheaper to transmit over
longer distances.
So whenever you have
intercity trains,
almost always they will be
overhead high voltage AC.
For subways, shorter
distances, tunnels,
you don't want to have
transformers everywhere.
And the other problem
with high voltage
is that it arcs more easily
between two pieces of metal.
So in a subway sys-- in
a subway train like this,
you don't have much space
between underneath the train
to fit things in with
proper electrical isolation.
So if it's an intercity
train, it's higher floor.
You have more space.
But if it's a Metro system,
often you have less space.
So if it's DC inside
the train and you
don't need transformers
[INAUDIBLE]
at very short intervals
in your system.
Yeah, so that was a
short parenthesis.
Commuter rail is another
kind of rail system.
So the stereotypical
description.
Vehicles operating in trains
with long station spacing.
This frequently.
Serving long trips
into the central city.
There's usually a large
balance between peak hour
and off-peak service.
So commuter rail to bring
people into work in the morning
and out of work [INAUDIBLE]
in [INAUDIBLE] afternoon.
So you often have
service every hour
or every two hours in
the middle of the day.
It's on the sign for
frequent service.
Your key decision--
the decisions
are fare collection strategies.
Are you going to put
gates on the whole system
as if it were a Metro system?
Are you going to
have paper tickets?
Some systems are moving
towards mobile phone ticketing
where you buy something
that flashes in colors
and proves that you've
bought a valid pass.
So different strategies
for fare collection.
Line length, how long-- how
far out from the city center
are you going to lay
track and provide service?
Are you going to through
route in the CBD?
That is, is the train going
to only get to the CBD
and turn back?
Or are you going
to cross the city
and provide service
on the other side
having crossed the [INAUDIBLE]?
That's pretty critical actually.
Because it's commuter
rail is very directional.
So if you don't have
a place near the city
to store your trains after
you have inbound service,
you'd have to then
take them out.
So you're running trips that
cost you money to operate,
and we're not
serving many trips.
So if you have through
routing and you
have a yard close
to the city center,
it might make more sense.
Station spacing is another issue
and extent of parking capacity.
Why parking?
Because commuter rail is often
accessed with a park and ride
service, right?
So you're usually-- you drive
to a commuter rail station.
You park there.
And then you take
the commuter rail.
Questions on commuter rail?
OK.
Some examples.
[INAUDIBLE] this
[INAUDIBLE] diesel.
So in some sections
it runs on diesel.
As it gets closer to the city
center, it uses electric power.
Here's Mumbai.
This one has a catenary.
So it's taking power
from these catenaries.
This is GO Transit in Toronto.
This is typical of commuter rail
having two levels, two decks,
fit more people in.
OK.
So what are the traditional
service concepts?
Bus on shared right of way.
Street car or let's say light
rail on a shared right-of-way.
Heavy rail on
exclusive right of way.
And then commuter or
regional rail on something
that is semi-exclusive or
exclusive right of way.
Sometimes commuter rail shares
the segments with freight.
So-- and that's
it's semi-exclusive.
Newer service concepts, BRT.
So we're looking at using
buses to operate something that
is more akin to light
rail or even to lighter
heavy rail, if you want.
So including exclusive lanes
and or transit signal priority
where the signals turn green
when one of these vehicles
approaches to not delay
the vehicle [INAUDIBLE]..
And then light rail on
exclusive right-of-way,
which makes it more
like heavy rail
if you look at the stereotypical
descriptions that we had here.
OK.
And what else is happening?
Increasing diversity.
Driver arrangements.
Instead of having people hiring
part-timers to cover the peaks
or having 10-hour days
but not five days a week.
And then payment by
vehicle type so you
as much for [INAUDIBLE]
for a heavy rail car as you
would for a bus.
So let's go back to
part-timers and 10-hour days.
Why are these
[INAUDIBLE] help increase
the efficiency,
[INAUDIBLE] efficiency,
of a bus or a rail system?
Why is that necessary?
AUDIENCE: Like as people that
just work in a peak period
where you need more--
if you're operating
more of your fleet
but if you don't actually
need them for the whole day.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: OK.
So that would be for
part-timers, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, part-timers.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Yeah, so you
might need more to run more
service only at the peaks.
And the peaks are
not long enough.
They're also not--
they're also not spaced--
they're kind of spaced eight
hours apart aren't they?
So an eight-hour
day doesn't really
work to cover both peaks.
So that's why you can do
that by hiring part-timers
or by extending the day to get
10 hours and cover both peaks.
OK.
Routing and scheduling.
So fixed, flexible,
advanced booking.
Yeah, so vehicle types.
We have all these minibuses,
articulated buses, rail cars,
bi-level rail cars, low floor.
We saw some examples.
Control options.
Traditionally it
was fixed block.
But now we have moving block.
And we have fancier
systems [INAUDIBLE]
collisions and to
actually control
the system to run faster
and more even headway.
And you have dual
mode operations.
So bus systems or
light rail systems
that work more like
buses but also more like
rails in some segments.
So in some cases, this dual
mode has more to do with power.
So it could be a bus that runs
electric in a tunnel section
but runs diesel [INAUDIBLE]
tunnel section like the Silver
Line here in Boston.
It could be having some
sort of [INAUDIBLE] system
that operates on streets as
a normal bus would but then
enters a corridor where it's
fully dedicated to the bus
system.
So it's operating
in both manners.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Why [INAUDIBLE]
I think [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
I'm not sure I follow.
I can't hear you very well.
But--
AUDIENCE: Oh, sorry.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
If you're
asking about why not run
diesel in the tunnel?
It's for exhausts.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah,
so there might be regulations.
You don't want diesel
exhaust in the tunnels.
So it's for health reasons.
A lot of the newer
buses, like hybrid buses
that are diesel electric,
because obviously
if you've got a fully electric
bus, there's no issue.
If you've got a diesel electric,
some of them have a [INAUDIBLE]
If you're entering
the tunnel you can
tell it to only use electric.
And it's [INAUDIBLE]
slower it will.
But it'll run only on electric.
And then get-- you turn that
off when you exit the station
to keep generating electricity.
Questions on these?
OK.
Rail versus bus.
So rail has higher capacity.
Bus has a lower capital costs.
It's cheaper to buy a bus than
to buy a rail or to build rail.
Buses, you buy the vehicle and
the streets are already there.
So you're not having
to build stations.
The unit operating costs
are lower for rail.
So if you look at the
average, and we'll
look at some of these costs,
unit cost by say, by trip,
by passenger trip.
Because so many people ride
rail, it's cheaper per ride
to provide rail
than to provide bus.
Bus, however, can
cover a wider network
because it's more flexible.
Rail tends to better
service quality.
Because it doesn't have traffic.
And it has a dedicated
right of way.
So, yeah.
And it has a stronger
land-use influence.
Because the stations are in map.
And you sort of know
the rail map of the city
much faster than you learn
about its bus network.
So there's a bias that people
have towards taking rail
over taking bus, even if
rationally taking a bus
would be faster.
You may not even be aware
of all of your bus options.
And fewer negative
externalities.
That's because electricity
that powers these is often
generated outside of
the city and brought in.
So the air pollution cost by
the consumption of electricity
for rail is not--
is not an externality that is
internalized in the city often,
if that makes sense.
So, right.
So bus is much more flexible.
And you can operate it
on any road [INAUDIBLE]
or on a guided right-of-way
or a designated right-of-way.
And it's more
prone to being used
in [INAUDIBLE]
mode nature, right?
So just the flexibility.
Let's look at the--
going back to the APTA
Fact Book of 2011.
And these are numbers for 2011.
Because they always do
these reports for two years
before the report comes out.
So how much was spent in
bus service in the US?
So 18, this is in millions,
so 18,000 million,
actually billion heavy rails
less and light rail even less.
And then commuter rail
is more expensive.
Paratransit is a form
of transit that is
provided to handicapped people.
And it's-- you reserve it.
You say, I need to be picked
up here and taken there.
And you get a window,
maybe a three-hour window,
so it'll schedule
a pickup and take
you to provide service for you.
So, because it's so dedicated,
it's expensive to run.
OK, in terms of-- that's in
terms of operating expenses.
How many trips are served?
So bus also provides
more than heavy rail,
because there are more bus
systems all over the US.
Heavy rail, but you can see
if you compare the operating
expenses with annual
unlinked passenger trips
that it's more efficient
per passenger, right?
And then light rail and
commuter rail and paratransit
are much smaller
contributors to this.
Let's go down to these
pale yellow ones.
Here we are dividing
operating expense
by revenue vehicle
hour or revenue vehicle
mile on length of trip.
So we got some
unit costs, right?
So you see the unit costs
for bus, $3.40 per bus ride.
For heavy rail $1.80.
For light rail $3.
For commuter rail $10.
And for paratransit $26.
So this is how much it costs
to run that service when
you divide it by the
number of people taking it.
Questions?
AUDIENCE: So like
in London, the bus
is like half the
price of the Tube?
For example, at least,
most of the time so
would that imply that
either the buses in London
are probably a lot
cheaper than these
or that they're
subsidizing the bus
trips because the less
affluent people tend to take
the bus versus the Tube?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
More the latter.
AUDIENCE: That take the bus?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
So, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So buses
tend to be more.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
I mean, it's
cheaper to run one bus.
But if you look at how
many people can ride a bus
and how many people
can ride a train, yeah.
The Tube unit cost basis is--
yeah, it's more efficient.
The other thing is that you
put Metro service in places
where there is high demand.
So it's somewhat
cyclical, right?
Bus service, you might have a
mandate to cover a big area.
So some of the bus corridors
might be operating on profit.
And some of them
might be, you're
doing it because you have a
mandate to provide service.
And it's running-- it's
underutilized and the price
that your cost per rider
might be much higher.
AUDIENCE: These are
all operating costs
to just to keep it running--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Yes, yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
No capital costs.
And we're not talking
about fares here.
So this is how much it
costs to pay the driver,
the fuel, the maintenance.
Yeah.
OK.
Let's look at mean
passenger load.
I think this is interesting.
So 10.7 for bus.
So if you look at if you take
a bus in the US at random,
the average number of people
in it will be 11 people.
Does that make sense?
Is that your experience?
Seems a little low.
So one way of
thinking about it--
maybe I can clear the
board a little bit here.
I'm sorry it's very--
yeah.
they're all used up.
One way of thinking about it
is let's think of the AM peak.
So, and let's just
keep it very simple.
So you have service
going this way
from one terminal to the other.
Let's say and A and B and
service going back, right?
And because this is
the AM peak and this
is the central
business district,
let's say that
everybody's going in.
Nobody's coming out.
So you have a lot
of people boarding
the bus closer to the city.
Well, yeah, let's do it the
other way more realistically.
People are boarding the bus.
And as they get to
the CBD, they alight.
They get off at the
city center, right?
So let's say that a bus--
this bus fits 45 people.
So that's the
people right there.
So what's the average
in that direction?
It's half of 45, right?
And then if you divide
45 by half and then
by half, because there's
only one direction
providing service,
you have 45 by four.
Right, 45 by four is 11.
So there you go.
Just making sense of it,
right, a quick check.
AUDIENCE: There is another
piece that a lot of us
have taken buses in Boston,
others in San Francisco where
there are a lot of people
who take the bus [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
And there is some of that in
some of these other modes.
So heavy rail.
For [INAUDIBLE] reasons, 25.
This is per car
not per train so--
AUDIENCE: Oh, [INAUDIBLE].
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: OK.
Light rail also by
car, although may
light rail systems or
single car or two car, so--
I think commuter rail is higher,
35.3 [INAUDIBLE] two things.
One is that your mostly
operating on the peak power.
So you're not providing
much service off peak.
Therefore, there's this
higher demand there.
The other thing is that
it [INAUDIBLE] right?
So these cars are bigger.
They have two decks sometimes,
and they fit more people.
So that's why you have
higher mean passenger load.
OK.
So just looking at some
sort of averages nationwide
and make some sense of them.
Riderships by mode
and [INAUDIBLE]
start with heavy [INAUDIBLE]
systems from two classes ago
we saw that the oldest systems
are the first ones to be built.
And they're in cities that
depends a lot on transit
and use a lot of transit.
So these five older systems,
this was the ridership in 2009.
If you look at seven newer
systems built after that,
that's the combined
rider, much lower, right?
So you see the older systems
are carrying a lot more people.
And if you look at the
change from '74 to 2009,
[INAUDIBLE] the old [INAUDIBLE]
grew 63% and [INAUDIBLE]
With light rail, you have--
you start with seven old
systems, 188 million.
It grew by 26%.
A lot of newer
systems, do you see
that, there are much more newer
light rail systems so there
are newer heavy rail systems.
Commuter rail, four
old, 12 new, same idea.
The older systems grew
by 36%, 12 new systems
carried much less than the
four old systems though.
And here's four bus.
We had 5--
5.4 billion.
It grew 10%.
So that's just
giving you an idea
of how heavily the [INAUDIBLE]
systems are being used.
If you look at what has
happened from 1999 to 2009,
so one decade, the number
of active vehicles 10%.
So the investments, the
supply in heavy rail
grew by 10%, though
the demand [INAUDIBLE]
case supply measured in
another way, revenue vehicle
miles operated, 20%, or 19%.
For light rail, we see that
many more vehicles are being
[INAUDIBLE] and much
more revenue models
are being operated.
So again, more investments in
light rail than in heavy rail.
And, yeah, commuter rail
is somewhere in between.
For bus it's much less.
It looks like there
is a higher level
of [INAUDIBLE] in light rail
systems than in other modes.
OK, and service trends by mode.
So we have here boardings
per revenue vehicle mile.
So this is a way of
measuring how much supply.
In 2009 this how much 5.2 for
heavy rail and light rail.
Heavy rail grew by 16%.
Light rail decreased by 15%.
Again, more investment
in light rail but more
of the growth happening
in heavy rail.
Commuter rail same thing.
Some of this could be
people, more people
moving towards cities and
not requiring commuter rail
or suburbanization, people
living in the suburbs
and working in the
suburbs for not
having to take commuter rail.
For loads, we see, again,
loads increasing in heavy rail,
decreasing somewhat or staying
flat in other [INAUDIBLE]..
So these are general trends.
OK.
[INAUDIBLE] do you have any
questions on these modes
and their characteristics
and the role they play in--
yes?
AUDIENCE: Two questions.
First of all, what exactly
[INAUDIBLE] and second of all
can you talk about why light
rail is [INAUDIBLE] being
so much more operated on than
[INAUDIBLE] why those changed.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: OK.
So revenue vehicle miles.
Let's start with the first one.
What is revenue vehicle mile?
It's a measure of the distance,
total distance covered
by a vehicle that
is serving trips.
So it excludes that
heads from garages
to the beginning of our
route or any other vehicle
movement where the vehicle
is not serving people.
It's not-- this doesn't
have its head sign on and--
if it's a bust, right?
So that answered
the first question.
And the second one
was, why is there--
why does there seem to be
investment in light rail
when it seems like the
ridership is decreasing
and the amount of
revenue vehicle miles
are going down as well?
So, this is more of a planning
and politics question, I think,
cities and urban planners.
Because light-- because
rail has more power
to change the urban landscape.
Because in people's
minds, it is more--
it's more physically
present and permanent.
There is a preference towards
rail systems over bus systems.
Metro is appropriate
for very large cities
that a lot of them--
a lot of those cities
that require Metro
already have Metro.
So what we're
seeing is that there
is a lot of cities
that are maybe not
as big to require Metro.
But they could use
a light rail system.
They could also use BRT.
But they have a bias towards
light rail in planning
and for political reasons.
A politician might
prefer to claim,
I built this train system, not
I put some buses on the road,
right?
So these are real factors that
influence the mode choice.
The other thing is that a
lot of these newer systems,
because they are
in smaller cities,
they bring the average down.
So--
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
[INAUDIBLE] even if I
could add on that [INAUDIBLE]
the US you had new light rail
systems in Cincinnati, in
Tucson, and Kansas City.
But even if-- but their
increase in ridership,
so there, their
contribution to the increase
in ridership of light
rail might not even
compensate for loss of
ridership in other cities
that have old systems like
Philadelphia or Boston.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Right.
AUDIENCE: And so if
Philadelphia has a decrease,
I'm not saying it
did, but if it did,
then it could wipe
out the increase
that Cincinnati contributed.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yep.
It goes both ways.
These are averages.
So-- any other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] by local
agency or like [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
It could be.
So the question is [INAUDIBLE]
commuter rail referred to
in terms of the operator?
Who operates
commuter rail and is
that one of the characteristics
that-- but yeah.
I didn't include that here.
Because there are many
different arrangements
for what commuter
rail is and if it's
publicly operated or privately
operated through a contract
through the public sector.
Yeah, there's all
sorts of arrangements.
Sometimes there's
a separate agency
that operates commuter rail.
And it's not the same agency
that operates the inner city
bus and Metro.
So--
AUDIENCE: You used
the word [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So commuter rail is usually
characterized by more service.
The purpose of commuter rail is
to bring workers into the city.
Right?
So you have a service that is
radial going into the city.
The frequency of
service is higher
in the AM peak and the
PM peak, lower off peak.
Whereas intercity is
more of a scheduled--
intercity rail is more like
airplanes and the airline
industry where you have a
schedule and trains leave
every hour or every two hours.
And you book in advance.
And right?
So slightly different
characteristics.
[INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: I had a
couple of questions.
Well, I guess the
first one is if you
go to pretty much any airport
and they have an airport
transit system, they have
automated-- it's automated
as platform screen
doors and all the like,
and we've been building those
in the US since the '70s,
why are there-- why is
that never put forth
except for a couple of
occasions in, I guess, Vancouver
and a couple of
very small systems?
That's the second part of it.
So is there any good
reason for that?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
My guess
is that you have more
space in airports.
And it's less political.
You have the stakeholders
of the airport,
the airport has
funding streams to--
for capital projects.
You have the space.
The airline has to use eminent
domain to build any system,
if that's what
you're talking about.
If you're talking about
building a new system.
In terms of retrofitting
an old system,
well, that's harder
than building a new one
from the beginning, right?
So the investment required to--
the station shutdowns
and all the headaches
that you have to deal with if
you're retrofitting a system,
putting in a new signal linked
system, all these things,
you might require
a new fleet that is
capable of operating this way.
So it's a heavy lift--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
--to do the retrofitting.
But it's being done.
If you look at London,
London's been doing it.
They're-- yeah,
the Jubilee Line,
which is the color silver
in the map of London,
is operating with--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
--with-- but from screen doors
in the center at least.
And--
AUDIENCE: Also the full
DLR system in London.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Yeah, yeah.
And that's-- it's funny, because
that's Docklands Light Railway,
right?
L is for light.
But it's Metro according
to what we covered today.
It's heavy rail.
AUDIENCE: And then the
second question was,
if you look at something
like cross-linked or RER
or something that's [INAUDIBLE]
which is your sort of hybrid
commuter rail but then
operate on transit very high
frequency--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Perfect questions.
So again, we talked
about stereotypes
and the lines are blurry.
And I think it's useful to--
the point of this is not to
really categorize everything
and be able to claim
this is a heavy rail.
This is a light rail.
It's more as just a
framework to think about
if you're a planner,
or a consultant,
and you're in charge of
deciding or helping your city
decide what mode to
use for some project,
here are the things
you should think about.
Here are the key decisions
that you have to make,
station spacing, capacity,
what are you dealing with?
So in that sense, this context
is-- this framework is useful.
But I wouldn't go--
I wouldn't use it to
necessarily classify everything
into one with one label.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So these
trends that you've shown
are pretty much all
[INAUDIBLE] the US systems?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Well, we have many pictures
from internationally, yeah.
AUDIENCE: You touched
on [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
There's Canada, Mumbai.
Right, so--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: OK.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yes, but the
trends, though [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Oh, yes, yes.
AUDIENCE: Ridership.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
That's right, yes.
AUDIENCE: That sort of stuff--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --is not quite
the same outside of the US?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Yeah, I'm
not as knowledgeable on the
trends in Europe and Africa
and Asia, South
America, though I'm
sure that other countries
and the European Union
have something similar
in terms of reporting.
So, yeah, I happen to know
the Fact Book and the NTD
statistics.
I'm familiar with them.
So I can go and refresh them
and look at the unit costs. ;
I'm sure you could
do the same thing.
I just haven't done it.
It would be interesting to see
how those trends have compared
[INAUDIBLE].
All right, if there are no more
questions, class is dismissed.
Please, meet with your teams and
pick a day for data collection.